thank you
protests in Kenya's Capital Nairobi are
met with a swift response
Security Forces fire tear gas to
disperse the crowds who've gathered to
demonstrate against the government
activists say these children were among
those caught up in the smoke
these people are peaceful we should be
allowed to the Muslim peacefully
in fact people who are very even
peacefully the police
and they even went ahead to tiagas those
who are in the houses
those who came out on the streets feel
betrayed they say they voted for
President William Ruto because he
promised to improve people's lives
instead he doubled taxes on Essentials
like fuel this at a time when inflation
was already running at eight percent
our problem is the cost of living is
high in Kenya we're unable to pay school
fees we don't have enough money and this
forces us to go for protests
suffered we have no food we have nothing
we can't work here with the protests
going on we do not know where to start
we plead with the government to come up
with Solutions
the government says the tax hikes were
necessary
Kenya has deaths to pay and increasing
levies would raise nearly one and a half
billion dollars a year
some of that is earmarked for affordable
housing and job initiatives right groups
have criticized Kenya's police for
cracking down on protests
the right to Peaceful demonstrations is
guaranteed in the Constitution
but the authorities say protests like
this one are illegal
any rally that's not cleared in advance
by the police is dispersed in the name
of National Security
Vincent Monaghan Al Jazeera